we start with breaking news from Peru
where president Pedro Castillo says that
he's dissolving Congress at installing
an emergency government a state of
emergency has also been declared and a
curfew has been announced the opposition
had been debating whether to impeach the
president for a third time Peru has
faced a string of political crises since
Castillo took off his 18 months ago
let's go live natalima at altazira's
Mariana Sanchez who can tell us more
about Congress being dissolved to what
happens next
well Adrian uh president Pedro Castillo
has indeed dissolved Congress this is a
an auto cool an auto couldn't tell which
uh we have seen in 1992 when fukhi Mori
former president Alberto figimori also
dissolved Congress now what has a
Castillo said he has said that he will
reorganize the Judiciary the
prosecutor's office that has all these
investigations that are uh that are
pointing at him at criminal acts that he
has committed uh criminal acts and he
has called the Armed Forces to patrol
the streets he said that he will soon
very soon call for Congressional
elections and in the meantime he will be
governing with
urgent increase why has Castillo done
this he says that he has sent 70
projects to Congress and they were all
rejected and that Congress had tried to
impeach him for treason which he calls
absurd
he has indeed survived to two
impeachment attempts uh this year and
last year and he said that Congress
wanted wants to impose uh Congressional
dictatorship uh now um
it just a 30 minutes sort of 30 minutes
before Garcia went on air to uh in this
message to the nation the uh chief of
the army resigned this was very
suspicious because uh the Army is a key
element in this uh in this situation
that is now uh moving in the last few
hours we had a seen more witnesses
talking about how Castillo's friends and
family uh were involved
supposedly in criminal acts and uh uh
receiving parts from different people so
the Congress at the same time was about
to begin a debate to impeach him in
about two hours from now they have uh
Advanced the hour they are now in
Congress speaking and it is possible
that this that they could indeed unseat
president Castillo so it is a very very
difficult situation it is a very it's
uncertain and really the key here Adrian
is we have to see what the military will
do because it is impossible to have a
good attack here with uh without the
military support and as far as the
people are concerned what's been their
reaction to the president's announcement
well there's some people in the streets
who were protesting in support of
Castillo because of this um uh debate
that was going to happen in a couple of
hours there's a lot of tension there's
calm and uh we have been seeing reports
from different uh army barracks and
different Army uh bases that everything
is calm so we have to see if the Army
will support this and also the
um the Marines and the Air Force it
won't happen just like that it has to
happen with all the Armed Forces
supporting Castillo so we will see what
what will happen in the next few minutes
or hours really it's uncertainty
uncertain what's happening right now
Maria Sanchez they're live in Lena for
the moment Mariana many thanks indeed